when you're getting on the ice and
layers of skaters are already racing
before you it can be very very noisy but
the second I step on the ice for my race
I've become hyper focused my name is
Brittany Bowe and I am an Olympic long
track speed skater speed skating is a
competitive sport raced around an oval
course athletes compete at speeds up to
36 miles per hour the fastest skater
wins and races can be so close champions
are determined by split seconds while
they compete inside during the Olympics
athletes train outdoors skating and
freezing temperatures and falling snow
the moment before the gun goes off is
one of the hardest moments of the race
there's this push-pull that's happening
because you want to be very calm relaxed
but at the same time you're nervous and
your heart is beating out of your chest
my vision and hearing becomes so narrow
it sounds like you're the only person in
there at this moment you could hear a
pin drop in the oval when you're hitting
corners a gravitational force feels like
it's trying to pull you right off of the
track
when you're going around the track at
these high speeds fighting the
gravitational forces the pain that you
feel in your legs is unimaginable it's a
sensation of heaviness and it almost
feels like your muscles are suffocating
because of all of the pressure when you
cross the finish line and you see a
number one next to your name it feels
like all of the pain that I just endured
was totally worth it
[Music]